not that it was easy to raise money
because I'd only directed one feature
before and that feature had not made its
money back so I didn't have much of a
track record
has experience impacted your financing
movies well it's a good question I think
every movie is different when it comes
to financing you know it's like some
movies lend themselves more to like
whether girl was very user friendly you
know it was a romantic comedy it was
easy it didn't offend anybody you know
so not that it was easy to raise money
because I'd only directed one feature
before and that feature had not made its
money back so I didn't have much of a
track record but we had Jane Lynch was a
friend of Trisha O'Kelly's and she had
agreed to star in it once Jane Lynch's
in something everybody wants to be in it
so we had a really great cast built
before we had any money you know which
is rare and I've never seen that happen
on anybody's movie you know I think Jane
Lynch being the linchpin of that that
movie was very specific to how that
movie got financed with six month rule
we found an investor who believed in me
like you know me and my business partner
went to the same high school that he
went to and now he's an incredibly
successful businessman and like I was
pitching six-month rule all over the
place and like I don't even know if he
read the script he believed in what we
were doing and you know was interested
in movies so he financed that and then
cut to the chase was this great amalgam
of just like $5,000 here $5,000 here
until we and we until we raised you know
over a hundred grand
all people who were just voting on
betting on us and that was a really
personal thing like people just wanted a
shreveport movie from a Shreveport boy
and and they got it so everyone is
different though but the key the only
consistent is that you have to take
every meeting you have to talk to
everybody because you never know where
that money's gonna come from and it's
always a surprise to me like we had an
experience where I had a driver for a
movie that I was on and he drove me to
set every day very cool guy liked me
very much at the end of the movie he's
like I have a friend that has connection
to money and I'm like should talk to my
business partner and
we were ended up secret-identity
financed this other movie with the
friend of the driver like who would have
thought but it comes from all over the
place but you gotta always be ready and
sometimes you have to ask the awkward
question who you give me money right and
so with crowdfunding it's good for
sounds like part of it but especially in
this landscape it sounds like it might
be tough for now I think it'd be tough
too I mean you know we raise 20 grand
and it was hard
I mean it's work every single day you
got to be out there and like you got to
be hitting people over the head with it
all the time
and Paul Osbourne always says that I
don't hit hard enough but I do I hit
really hard and I was able to raise
$20,000 but it was by hook or by crook I
pulled that money you know and you know
from from a ton of really great people
but I don't know how much more you can
get without some some kind of hook you
know what I mean like the perfect
sweater whatever those things that make
a million dollars I don't know how they
do it but I would love to get in on that
you